sau những ngày hội lớn kiện diệm tảm mươi năng cách mạng thẳng tảm vào quốc hình hay thẳng chính,
đêm ngày bà thẳng chính, tại hành quảy đá diễn ra cuộc tiến quan đầy xuất đồng.
Theo kế hoạc, quan tạo xuất 2 xuất hủy hụt Tau S.A.S.S.Ba,
chờ gần sảo chăm cánh bộ chính xí thuộc quan khu bẩy, quân khu chính, quân chủ hệ quân và quân bản bà bún,
từ ca hàng đổi đến ca sây gòn và ca ca trụ chuyển tả nắng ngại trang.
Các chính xí đã có mặt trên Tau Tì sớm, quân trang ngày ngắn, chờ đến dựa tạo khơi hành.
Vẫn những tiến hát tư vui như ngày đầu mới ra hả nội,
tinh thân của những người lĩnh trẻ hôm nay, còn thêm liêm buổi nghiêm tự hào khi đã hoàn thành xuất giận vụ được dau.
Dưới sân gà, những hình ảnh sản dị, những tràn chứng nghĩa tình đã diễn ra,
những cái bóc tay thật chặt, những lời trảo âm áp,
lụ cười xem lãnh nước bồi hồi, tất cả đã tạo nên đức trang sinh động về tình quân sân khảnh bó,
về nêm tự hào khi được có thật chòng sự két lịch sử của đất nước.
Không ký trang nghiêm vương tận ảnh áp thình gời khi các đoàn quân lên đưa tời thủ đô.
Tính còi tầu phang lên, đưa các chính xí trở về đơn vị,
mang theo kì nghiệm khó quên về những ngày tập liển sân khô,
và khoảng khách quyền nghiêm trên khoảng trường gà bên.
Đời với người dân, đây là phút xây hội tụi nghiêm tinh và tình yêu với những người đến trẻ.
Đời về các chính xí đó là dù án sâu đậm trong hình trình dành nghiệm,
có nghĩến tả trường thành.
Bột chia tay dàng dịt như thế liên đã kép lại chuyển ngày hội lớn để lại sư âm lấn động về tình thình bàn kết,
nhêm tự hào sân tộc và mối quan hệ cà sân quân sân bên trạp.